voy a hacer el mismo problema de
sustracción o resta dos veces aquí vemos
que le vamos a restar 172 a 629 y lo que
tengo aquí son esos mismos números
ampliados escribí 629 como 600 más 20
más 9 y también reescribir 172 el 1 es
100 y lo escribí aquí el 7 está en la
posición de las decenas y aquí escribir
70 y el 2 que está en la posición de las
unidades sólo representa 2 y en un
momento vamos a ver porque es útil de
esta manera de escribir los números
empezamos a restar en el lugar de las
unidades tenemos 9 menos 2 que
claramente vemos que es 7 y de este lado
también tenemos 9 menos 2 el signo que
nos indica la resta lo tenemos de este
lado y el resultado es 7
pero algo interesante pasa cuando
llegamos al lugar de las decenas vamos a
tratar de restar 27 osea le vamos a
quitar 7 al 2 y todavía no hemos
aprendido cómo hacer cosas con números
negativos es algo que vamos a aprender
en el futuro así que por ahora tenemos
un problema cómo le restamos un número
grande a uno pequeño bueno tenemos una
herramienta que se llama reagrupamiento
y que podemos usar en este caso algunas
veces le llamamos pedir prestado y es
por eso que esta forma de escribir es
valiosa cuando tratamos de restarle 7 a
este 2 realmente estamos tratando de
restarle 70 a 20 y no podemos restarle
70 a 20 pero tenemos otro valor en la
posición de las centenas así que vamos a
quitarle 100 a este 600 y nos quedan 500
y le vamos a dar ese 100 a la posición
de las decenas si le damos 100 a las
decenas que nos quedan tenemos 100 más
20 y el resultado es igual a 120 y con
esto que hice no cambie el valor de 629
tomé 100 de las centenas y los pase a
las decenas fíjense bien 500 más 120 más
9 es igual a 629 no hemos cambiado el
valor y como hacemos eso de este lado
bueno pues tomamos 100 de este 600 y
aquí nos queda 5 en el lugar de las
centenas o sea 500 y si le damos 100 a
la posición de las decenas vamos a tener
10 decenas así que aquí nos queda un 12
esto ahora va a ser igual a 12 y fíjense
este 2 en el lugar de las decenas
representa 12 decenas que es igual a 120
así que esta es otra manera de hacer lo
mismo que hicimos acá no es magia es
como pedir prestado le decimos a este 6
préstame 1 y aquí quedan 5 entonces
porque este 2 se convierte en 12 porque
le sumamos 10 en realidad sumamos 10
decenas o 100 que es lo mismo
tomamos 100 de aquí y 600 se vuelve 500
y 20 se vuelve 120 y ahora estamos
listos para restar 12 decenas menos
siete decenas es igual a cinco decenas o
podemos decir 120 menos 70 es igual a 50
y finalmente tenemos la posición de las
centenas cinco menos uno es igual a
cuatro realmente significa 500 menos 100
es igual a 400 y de este lado 500 menos
100 es igual
400 y el resultado es 457 que es lo
mismo que 457